[Music]
Devonte is with us in Norfolk Virginia
hi Devonte how are you I'm good Mr
Ramsey thank you so much for taking my
phone call sure what's up um so me and
my wife are about
$85,000 in debt um we're both acting dut
the military um in the
Navy um and that debt is
about I want to say a couple like couple
cards credit cards um no student
loans um two cars and a vending machine
um I was my question is do we keep
our um account separate until we pay off
our individual debts no or do we no no
you don't have individual debts just
like I was just explaining to her a
second ago now when you're married you
need to combine
everything the oldfashioned marriage
vows said for richer for poorer in
sickness and in health unto thee all my
worldly Goods I
pledge and so um you have joined and you
are one a and so just put it all in a
pile all of your income in a pile all of
your dead in a pile and work it as one
unit all the way through and you number
one you'll get a lot more uh a lot
better marriage relationship by doing
that but number two you'll actually make
more ground uh financially and
mathematically by doing that and so what
do you owe on your
cars um well she bought a car brand new
which um I cosigned um I have a car
that's at 15,000 and hers is
it is at 30,000 right now yeah and so
45,000 of your 80,000 is cars and what's
your household
income our household income
um with bah which is basic housing
allowance mine alone is 48 and I think
she makes around the same probably about
45,000 then there's no possible way you
should have $330,000 car when you're
$80,000 in
debt that's
insanity this car was a really dumb
idea and what I would do if I woke up in
your all shoes is I would look
two of you looking at it together but
I'm getting rid of the $30,000 car and
uh it's almost half of your debt that
one thing a and it was dumb you could
not afford that car and you bought more
car than you should have bought if I
woke up in your shoes I'd sell that and
and I would start to plow through this
debt together and uh again start talking
about our household income and you don't
even know what she makes I mean you guys
really really really really are going to
start working on the same page here